i gotta ask how did you force survive we
don't talk about what happened to
divisionals hey babe let's close your
window don't you dare
dad get me out of here
okay not quite the game script we need
to eat the week already we just crashed
[Music]
why is everyone worried derek will carry
us all to safety how did you survive
while i was gone
i decide where gronk goes always so
brady gets to have a shirtless outburst
i have a genius plan eridano go do
things i still love a jersey swap grade
17. uh yikes not looking so good for
mike mcdaniel sorry but lance isn't
quite ready yo did we crash sorry i
don't feel turbulence once again i'm a
send the herd common mistake but i'm a
human man oh lord what's the conference
round like
welcome to your nightmare it's a zack
trap y'all uh how the [ __ ] am i gonna
spend this tomography on tuesday oh hell
okay let's see uh
yay
they're in a better place now the promo
[Music]
doing great big mac just keep flying
this bad boy down i'm gonna run it into
the ground wait no just stand by this
that's a good decision